vous le disais on l'a appris il y a
quelques instants la rumeur un circulé
c'est ces dernières heures le président
américain Joe Biden est donc en visite
surprise au moment où je vous parle à
qui Eve la capitale kraignée vous avez
apercevoir ses premières images
semble-t-il du coup on voit du chef de
la Maison Blanche qui est donc a priori
va se rendre c'est l'image qu'on a ici à
l'écran à l'ambassade américaine de Kiev
il était attendu en Pologne Joe Biden
GOTY rabbinsky on va peut-être décrypter
ensemble en attendant une prise de
parole en tout cas annoncé comme comme
tel du chef de la Maison Blanche il
était censé partir ce soir cette nuit
même direction la Pologne Joe Biden pour
discuter de la possibilité d'accroître
la présence des troupes américaines ou
non sur le sur le terrain ça paraît en
même temps logique qui s'arrête à Kiev
sans prévenir tout le monde en amont
d'autant qu'on s'est contexte
extrêmement extrêmement sensible il y a
cette alerte anti-aérienne qui a été
lancée il y a quelques instants
peut-être une attaque russe lancée
aujourd'hui tout le pays des missiles
lancés comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs
assez assez souvent ces dernières ces
dernières semaines oui effectivement
d'ailleurs il y a probablement une
cause à effet entre ce que vous signalez
c'est-à-dire l'arrivée de Joe Biden
acquiesv et cette alerte bien évidemment
que quand vous vous déplacez de la sorte
dans un terrain de guerre et que vous
êtes le président des États-Unis vous
n'allez pas donner d'horaires exacts
pour pour dire à quelle heure vous serez
à qui à quelle heure vous serez en
Pologne ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y
avait d'une part il y avait deux choses
il y a deux choses dans ce dans ce
voyage dans cette visite il y a d'une
part bien sûr la question des besoins
Ukrainiens en termes non seulement
d'aviation mais en termes de défense
face à inoffensive russe et aussi en
termes parce que on en parle c'est
toujours contradictoire mais en termes
d'attaque c'est-à-dire que si on veut
arriver un jour à une situation où des
négociations seraient envisageables ce
qui n'est pas le cas pour l'instant mais
si on veut t'arriver à ce jour-là ça
veut dire qu'il faut donner aux
Ukrainiens les moyens de repousser les
troupes russes en dehors de la frontière
après il il y a quelque chose qui peut
être négocié pas avant donc ça c'est la
première question et la réponse de Joe
Biden est importante parce que est-ce
qu'il sera d'accord pour livrer ou pour
faire livrer des avions de chasse qui
sont capables de reconquérir pour les
Ukrainiens la le contrôle de de l'espace
aérien ou bien est-ce qu'il dira non
c'est encore trop tôt ou alors beaucoup
trop risqué puisque ça serait une
manière de se disant de se dévoiler
encore plus aux côtés des Ukrainiens
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
visite en Pologne vous savez que les
Polonais sont extrêmement
fermes derrière les Ukrainiens d'autant
plus qu'il craignent pour eux et se
disent si finalement on laisse tomber
l'Ukraine d'une manière ou d'une autre
et bien c'est nous qui sommes les
prochains devant les devant les Russes
alors tout ça bien sûr fait allusion à
tout ce que la Pologne a vécu par le
passé dans son histoire trois partages
trois disparitions et à chaque fois les
Russes étaient partis prenante
cette la Russie pardon était parti
prenante dans ce dépeçage donc il y a
quelque chose de très fort pour pour les
Polonais et puis vous savez que ce sont
eux qui sont par exemple capables non
seulement de livrer des chars léopards à
l'Ukraine puisqu'ils en ont dans leur
dans leur dotation mais aussi
éventuellement des avions de fabrication
soviétique que les pilotes ukrainien
pourraient manœuvrer et sont pour
lesquels ils sont habilités aller à les
conduire et à les employer donc là aussi
il y a quelque chose sur le plan
militaire qui est important cette visite
a été déjà importante pour ces deux
raisons la le caractère surprise de
celle à de la visite de Joe Biden à Kiev
la rend encore plus si j'ose dire
scénarisé voilà voilà l'idée c'est quoi
c'est aussi peut-être de dire de
réaffirmer le soutien évidemment aux
Ukrainiens quelques jours après les mots
d'Emmanuel d'Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État français qui a appelé à
intensifier le soutien à l'Ukraine de
ces questions en termes de
de logistique est-ce qu'il faut
renforcer encore les moyens ou pas la
question des F16 vous l'évoquez qui est
réclamait toujours par les
Ukrainiens
l'idée évidemment c'est d'adresser aussi
un message fort à la Russie il y a
Vladimir Poutine qui doit s'exprimer
demain qui doit prononcer un message
important à sa population ça sera
d'autant fort à mettre en parallèle bien
sûr si vous voulez on est toujours enfin
il vaut mieux être dans le symbolique
que dans l'actif c'est-à-dire il vaut
mieux être dans le le déclaratif dans le
narratif plutôt que de s'envoyer des
obus sur la figure donc tant mieux mais
effectivement tout ça peut servir pas de
prétexte mais de prélude à un engagement
plus important de la part de l'Occident
et également comme vous citer le
discours de demain le Vladimir Poutine
ça peut être aussi un prélude à quelque
chose qui ressemblerait à une
contre-offensive ou à une offensive donc
évidemment ça son importance maintenant
quand vous me disiez est-ce que il
s'agit d'affirmer encore plus le soutien
à probablement mais est-ce que il n'y a
pas une forme de lassitude à la fois
bien sûr des Ukrainiens mais aussi de
tous ceux qui sont partis prenantes dans
cette affaire en disant jusqu'où peut-on
réaffirmer un soutien verbal aux
États-Unis les choses se sont
compliquées au Congrès c'est là-bas
qu'on vote les financements et l'effort
l'effort de guerre on sait que Joe Biden
sur la scène intérieure le scénario
c'est quand même durci le scénario c'est
durci parce que vous avez des
républicains effectivement qui
contrôlent la Chambre des Représentants
et qui jusqu'ici en attendant les
élections de meetum c'était plutôt
prudent et avait marché avec Baelen dans
le soutien à l'Ukraine d'autant que vous
avez quand même dans le parti
républicain un vieux fond anti-rus et
anticommuniste qui fait que on soutient
plutôt ceux qui sont contre Poutine mais
là c'est complètement différent parce
que pour les années pour les
républicains il s'agit de se démarquer
aussi de Biden de se démarquer aussi
d'un certain nombre de on va dire de
d'exagération
de certaines marches de certaines
fractions du parti républicain et donc
ça peut se manifester par la volonté de
resserrer à nouveau les cordons de la
bourse dans le la j'allais dire dans les
les subventions les fonds apportées à
l'Ukraine donc ça peut être aussi
quelque chose qui accélère le phénomène
et accélère l'histoire c'est-à-dire que
si on veut quelque chose de définitif en
faveur de l'Ukraine en supposant que les
Russes aussi pourraient faire quelque
chose définitif il faut peut-être se
presser d'où la visite cette visite
double encore une fois à la fois à Kiev
c'était pas prévu mais c'était plausible
et puis à Varsovie parce que c'est aussi
Varsovie qui a un rôle central à la fois
dans les livraisons d'armes à l'Ukraine
et aussi parce que il y a cette crainte
bon vous savez très bien que les
rhodontadent des des partisans de
Poutine à la télé consiste souvent à
dire mais il faut il faut aller jusqu'à
Varsovie bon ça fait partie du du
décorum mais c'est quand même ce sont
des paroles qui sont ouvertes et
d'autant plus diffusées qu'elles le sont
qu'elles sont autorisées par le chef du
Kremlin on m'indique Gauthier que nous
sommes en